[Music]
[Applause]
Jay skursky covers the bills the beat
rider for the Buffalo News
Jay thanks for joining us I just
mentioned with 151 to go in the third
quarter Buffalo is up 27-10
and then what happened why did it go
south in a hurry
yeah the sort of the same problems that
have been plaguing this team since their
bye week they're they're turning the
football over at much too often of a
pace and their defense is not getting
the stops that it was getting before the
second half of games uh since the bye
week they have been outscored 43-12 that
was uh their their strength really the
first six weeks of the season they went
five and one in those six weeks and they
had outscored teams 84-17 in the second
half of games so for whatever reason uh
whether it's just a lack of
concentration uh certainly a
carelessness with the football but they
are uh after after halftime just not as
sharp as they are at the start of games
and it's now it's coming back to cost
them
but why does Vegas still like them as
the Super Bowl favorite
that's a great question I think because
the fact that Josh Allen is healthy
number one right he proved that
yesterday there was so much talk about
you know this elbow injury that he
suffered against the Jets and what kind
of impact would he miss time uh clearly
none of that you know came to be he was
able to play and he looked to be Josh
Allen so I think as long as you've got a
quarterback like Josh Allen and I think
there's a belief externally outside of
Buffalo internally in Buffalo that he is
going to get this clean up this this
team went through a stretch like this
last year too and they came out the
other side of it and I think we're
playing probably the best football of
any team in the league going into the
postseason so you know they've Sean
McDermott has talked a lot about how
there are going to be challenges
adversity throughout any season and
they've really kind of run into their
adversity now here after the buy against
the Jets and yesterday against the
Vikings we had Ross Tucker former NFL
player on last hour and he said there
were two things that stood out when
you're on the goal line you got to make
sure you know you got to get a clean
snap you gotta have that exchange gotta
make sure no matter what worst case
scenario it's a it's a safety also with
a fourth down pass nobody has to
intercept it
but knock it down and if that ball is
knocked down instead of going for the
hero play
then we have a different result there
yeah did anybody did Sean McDermott talk
about you know instructing you know make
sure you have a clean exchange or knock
down the ball in that fourth you know
downplay with Justin Jefferson
he did not specifically mention it after
the game but quite frankly he didn't
need to cam Lewis the player in in
question there uh the same the first
first career started safety we should
mention that uh this is a new position
for him going against Justin Jefferson
pretend you know potentially the best
wide receiver in the NFL that's a
challenge but listen he knows he knew he
needed to knock that ball down he didn't
and he admitted it afterward he was as
hard as he possibly could have been on
himself understandably so uh but that is
just a mental error right that is a
situation where you need to know if I
knocked this football down we win the
game it's that simple and he didn't do
it did he want to make an interception
did he want to you know get his name
into the into the newspaper into the
highlights that kind of thing I don't
know he says he's not a selfish player
that was a selfish play well he made it
into the highlights he's in the
Highlight James he's he certainly did
yeah and that's going to be one that
that lives on for years too but yeah and
then you know with listen with Alan and
Mitch Morris how many thousands of times
have they done that together yeah it's
it's a mistake it's it's an error it's
it's what unfortunately we've seen from
Josh Allen the last few weeks here
carelessness with the football whether
that's receiving a snap or making
ill-advised throws he is not taking good
care of the football it's go it reminds
us a lot of 2018 when he was a rookie in
2019 he had to learn his lesson about
taking care of the football for some
reason that's gotten away from him and
and the issue that I'm seeing Dan is
that he is not taking the easy
completions he is not taking what
defenses are giving him and right now
he's trying to force it he's trying to
make every play happen all at once he
doesn't need to do that and and that is
something I think the coaching staff
needs to get out of him right now yeah
it's almost like September was too easy
for him finish this sentence if this
team does not make the Super Bowl
it's a massive disappointment right I
mean they were the preseason favorites
that that has been since that season
since their season last year ended in
such disappointing fashion in Kansas
City everything about this year has been
about making the Super Bowl the first
step in that is about trying to get the
number one seed in the postseason that
was the goal for this team they are Owen
three Excuse Me Owen four on the road in
the playoffs under Sean McDermott
they're 3-0 at home so there is a
significant sample size that says this
team in the postseason at home is tough
to beat they have not figured out a way
to win on the road and that's why these
games right now are so big because they
are they had the inside track and really
controlled their own destiny for the
number one seed that has sort of Gone
Away now and they have really used up
their all of their margin for air I I
still think this is a playoff team I no
longer know whether this is the number
one seed in the AFC and that's going to
make their road to that Super Bowl that
much more difficult Jay thanks for
joining us we appreciate it thank you
for having me Dan that's Jay skursky he
covers the bills for the Buffalo News